[Musique]
simus narco papounet ou encore duchesse
ils sont 235 chiens et chats au sein du
refuge de plaisir à vouloir trouver une
famille d'adoption chaque année la SPA
de plaisir organise deux weekends de
journées portes ouvertes elodit tu es
chef d'équipe à la Société protectrice
des animaux du de de plaisir quels sont
les objectifs des journées portes
ouvertes ça va être de faciliter l'accès
au au refuge les ren des animaux on est
vraiment ouvert à tout public ces
journéesl de maximiser les adoptions
d'avoir de belles adoptions pour autant
qu'elles soit toujours responsable et
c'est aussi des moments d'échange
puisqu'on a des gens qui vont venir
juste par exemple pour avoir des
conseils et aussi faire de la
sensibilisation pour la protection
animale mais avant d'ouvrir les portes
au public il faut notamment laver les
boxes préparer les chiens et les
sortir l divine avant l'ouverture des
des portes du coup donc vous êtes en
train de nettoyer les boxes des des
chiens pourquoi c'est important de
nettoyer les boxes des animaux ils ont
le droit tout comme nous d'avoir une
hygiène de vivre dans des
il mér
mmeent de balade ou de par et ils sont
dans des conditions nickel pour une
question de santé aussi vérifier en même
temps de ça permet de contrôler aussi si
certains sont malades ou pas et pour se
préparer à cette journée les bénévoles
promènent les chiens je vais aller avec
maris et cassgin en
balade combien de temps de de balade est
organisé avec avec chaque chien et
qu'est-ce que ça leur permet pour cette
journée de portes ouvertes donc chaque
chien on une promenade à peu près de 30
35 minutes ça leur fait beaucoup de bien
parce que ça les sort bon B de déjà de
leur box c'est aussi un moment de
conivance avec la personne avec lequel
avec lequel il sont vous êtes avec
casassgin dit granouche est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu plus de de ce
chien et Ben granouche est là déjà
depuis plusieurs mois c'est un chien
très attachant bon qui a besoin de se
dépenser quand même pas mal il a fait
déjà des canic cross où il s'est très
bien défendu c'est vraiment un chien qui
n'est pas méchant qui n'est pas du tout
agressif qui est dynamique mais très
mignon une balade qui dépense et
canalise les chiens du refuge mais il
est déjà temps pour cassegin de rentrer
lui et 234 autres animaux de compagnie
attendent d'être adoptés à la SPA de
plaisir cet été
16488 animaux ont été abandonnés sur les
routes de France en 2022 la France était
une nouvelle fois tristement championne
des abandons